j - avant la 100e édition de l'open de
france de golf les joueurs sont arrivés
aujourd'hui au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
alors après les interviews et les
séances photos les sportifs ont pu
tester le parcours dans l'après midi
cette année les 60000 spectateurs pour
observer les têtes d'affiché françaises
comme alexander levy
déjà vainqueur de deux us open tour à 25
ans et de victor dubuisson 72e joueur
mondial et qui a participé à la ryder
cup 2014
l'open de france 2016 organisé jusqu'à
ce dimanche a également attiré cette
année
rory mcilroy numéro trois mondial la
star nord irlandaise n'était plus revenu
sur le parcours depuis 2010 c'est mikel
et demi d'euros était bien évidemment
sur place s'écouter c'est bon d'être de
retour de revenir dans ce tournoi
seulement deux ans de la ryder cup qui
se tiendra ici je pense que c'est une
bonne chose de supporter l'european tour
cette 100e 100e édition c'est avec
l'organisation
on sent que cette année ça c'est
vachement pas comment dire pas améliorée
mais mais on s'en tire beaucoup plus fou
plus d'émulation à 7 pour cette semaine